We've spent the last two and a half days going
through all the submissions and various other
reports from the Council in relation to the
Long Term Plan, which looks forwards 10 years.
I think the main things are pretty clearly,
the new stadium that we've ticked off for
Coldstream Road, Northern Rangiora.
It's a very big project in the history of
this district, but I think quite clearly by
the submissions, it severely needed and very
much wanted by a large part of our community
and while we recognise it's expensive, it
will add a huge amount to our sporting and
recreational provision in the district.
For me personally, I think probably the most
important thing is our continuation of the
programme in the Redzones, now called Regeneration
Areas of Kaiapoi and also Pines/Kairaki.
It's proceding of course, new roads are going
in as we speak, but all on top of that, as
we develop sportfields and other recreational
things in Kaiapoi.
It will be really good to see that happening
over the next year and following years.
And of course we also dealt with the question
of refuse collection, the famous three bins
discussion that's been going on for years
and we seem to have consulted to death.
We had to do it again this year, because there
are rating implications
and it gives people a choice.
They can stay exactly as they are if they
wish, or very close to what they are.
You can't avoid the yellow top bin, but all
the others, there's choices around it and
over the next 12 months you can expect to be asked what you want to have for your particular household.
It's against the background of some challenge.
The collapse of the mixed-paper market in
China for recyclable paper is severely impacting
the whole country and we're not isolated in
that, so that's adding a little bit to the
rates for refuse collection, and that's mostly
about recyclables.
So, it's been a rewarding exercise and we
want to thank everybody who submitted.
It was very helpful to us and because we had
a large number of submissions, that makes
the job easier in many ways, because we have a very clear indication of what the community wants.